Eu
tive trombose [música]
na perna esquerda, por causa disso tive
que retirar útero, colocas.
[música] E depois logo já fiz a cirurgia
de varizes. Foi tratamento [música] com
40 g de rivar, 900 mg de diosn e com
isso, [música] desde abril até aqui, até
semana passada, eu tinha engordado 8 kg.
De 98 [música] fui para 106. Eu tava com
falta de ar, a minha perna muito inchada
também. Estou na menopausa há há 3 anos
e tenho 60 anos, né? E foi um efeito
sanfona, isso foi muito traumático para
mim. E agora parece que ficou mais
difícil perder por conta da minha idade,
né? [música] Já fiz tratamento com
suplementos, vitaminas, com chás, só que
só ven engordando, retirei o glúten, o
leite, sofro muito com isso, sinto
muitas dores na barriga, tenho problema
de alopécia e como você vê aqui, ó, o
meu cabelo continua caindo, toma
minoxidil, tem uma super falha aqui no
meu início aqui, ó, do cabelo. Desde os
32 anos eu faço várias dietas [música]
aí tentando emagrecer e manter o peso.
Eu chego até emagrecer, sabe? Mas eh com
o tempo eu vou entrando no efeito platô
e [música] acabo engordando novamente.
Então foram várias várias tentativas de
emagrecer durante todos esses anos, dos
32 ao 70 que eu estou hoje. [música] E
isso me prejudicou muito a minha massa
muscular. em algumas delas e chegou a
afetar até um pouco dos meus ossos.
[música]
Aos 45 anos foi detectado em mim o
hipotiroidismo
e desde então eu tomo o Cintroide.
[música]
Mas eu tenho todos aqueles sintomas que
o Dr. Renan fala no nosso curso. Eu
tenho [música] unhas fracas, meu cabelo
cresce muito devagarzinho, tá fraquinho
também, minha pele é seca, eu tenho
dores pelo corpo. São vários, vários
sintomas que eu tenho. Tive dois filhos
e casei com 53 kg e hoje tô aqui com 69
[música]
kg eu estava. e nunca conseguiu
emagrecer o suficiente para ter os
exames eficazes. Hoje eu tô com
colesterol 332.
Olá, meu nome é I, tenho 76 [música]
anos e confesso que entrei nesse desafio
desacreditando, porque já participei de
outros, que emagreci tanto quanto, mas
nenhum que me desse as instruções, os
ensinamentos que eu recebi do Dr. Renan
há muito tempo. Venho travando lutas e
lutas com problemas de saúde. Eu tenho
esteatose hepática grau dois. Eu sou
préulínica.
Eu tenho problemas
no pulmão, eu tenho nódulos no pulmão.
Há pouco tempo tive suspeita de câncer
[música] no sangue. Aquela ficha
que nos foi dada [música] de avaliação,
eu gabaritei 83 pontos. 83 pontos aquela
avaliação. Aqui tem um problema de
insônia, sou tenho problema de estresse,
tive queda [música] no cabelo. Olha só
aqui a entrada. Eu tinha três vezes mais
o cabelo que eu tenho. Eu eliminei
3,800. E assim eu senti que a minha
perna desinchou, minha [música] falta de
ar passou e eu quero continuar. Eu
entrei no 5 em7, perdi 3,
e para mim foi uma vitória.
>> Tava com 85 kg 700, hoje estou com
81,900. Estampar de 3 kg
800 g.
>> Diminuir 5 cm de cintura e 3,5 kg
durante o desafio cinco em 7. [música]
>> E eu tenho certeza que agora vai. Agora
desbloqueou.
Aí a chavinha e eliminei 3,900 em 5
dias.
>> E eu tô
gente, bom dia. Bom dia. Eu tirei o
depoimento sem querer aqui. [risadas]
Bom dia. Bom dia. Bom dia, meninas. Bom,
deixa só. Vamos lá que eu quero que
vocês vejam esse final. Apertei o botão
sem querer, me perdoam.
>> Deixa eu mostrar aqui para vocês.
>> Sabe, ainda falta até domingo tô fazendo
tudo certinho e eu tô muito esperançosa.
Muito esperançosa. É gratidão minha
palavra para você, doutor. Muito
obrigada. Dessa vez eu encontrei o
caminho certo. Eu tô muito feliz por
isso. Quando eu comecei essa semana eu
tava com 102 kg. E hoje, para minha
surpresa, [música] quando eu subi na
balança, eu tava com 98 kg. Então assim,
eu vi que realmente eu tive um um
sucesso que eu nunca antes alcancei,
sabe, nessa minha luta de assim
constante, essa luta secular, né, contra
a balança.
>> Muito obrigada, Dr. Renato. Muito
obrigada,
>> gente. Me desculpa, Talito. Tá bom, tô
aqui. [risadas]
Bom dia, gente. Seja muito bem. Eu tô,
apertei tudo errado aqui. [risadas]
[roncando] É bom que vocês vem que é ao
vivo mesmo, né?
Bom dia, bom dia, bom dia, bom dia,
meninas. Bom, desculpa, gente, eu o
negócio aqui mudou aqui na tela, eu
apertei sem querer. Sejam muito
bem-vindos à nossa, a nossa quarta aula
do desafio do jejum. Mas calma, eu vou
entregar isso aqui, tá li? [risadas]
Obrigada por devolverem o meu sonho. Não
sonho de beleza, mas o meu sonho de ter
saúde para brincar com o meu [música]
netinho. É uma graça.
E é isso, meninas. Bom dia. Bom dia. Bom
dia. Sejam muito bem-vindas à nossa
quarta aula do desafio do jejum. Bom,
meninas, olha só, vamos lá.
Quarta aula. Desculpa, tá? Vocês
chegaram aqui, apertei os negócio
errado, saiu que [risadas]
acontece. Mas o que eu queria mostrar
para vocês, porque é isso aí, eu quero
que vocês sintam mais leve. A gente já
não tem mais essa cerimônia mais não.
Aqui já é todo mundo de casa. E eu
queria que principalmente vocês vissem
esse esse finalzinho desse depoimento de
mulheres que participaram, né, do nosso
desafio do jejum em algum momento.
E que quando você chega aqui, ah, eu
quero quilos na balança, mas o mais
legal é você ter consciência, pera aí,
eu quero ter energia para brincar com o
meu neto, quero ter energia para brincar
com meu filho, eu recupero minha
autoestima, tô com menos dor no corpo,
tô me sentindo bem, mais leve, com mais
alegria, felicidade e é isso. Então,
essa mentalidade, essa mentalidade de
visão de longo prazo é o que me
impressionou aqui nesse nosso desafio.
Lembra lá no começo da nossa primeira
aula que eu tinha feito uma pesquisa com
vocês e a maioria de vocês não falaram
que queriam só aquilos na balança, a
maioria falou que o tópico principal
mais citado foi o quê? Qualidade de
vida. Quero viver mais, quero viver
melhor. E é isso que a gente tá
construindo aqui. É isso que a gente tá
construindo aqui. Portanto, meninas,
sejam muito bem-vindas, porque hoje, na
nossa quarta aula, a gente vai falar
tudo sobre intestino, tudo sobre sono e
vamos falar tudo sobre dietas,
ciclagens, dietas. tem um universo de
coisas pra gente começar a a cuidar
aqui. E é isso. Vocês querem ter energia
para brincar, para cuidar de filho,
vocês querem ter energia para brincar
com neto. Vocês querem ter energia para
cuidar dos seus pais que talvez são
idosos, dependem de você. Então tem
muita coisa, então tem muita coisa para
acontecer.
>> [roncando]
>> A gente tá só na quarta aula e tem muito
mais aprendizado. Portanto, nossa quarta
aula do desafio do jejum começa agora.
Então, o que que te espera nessa nossa
quarta aula? Primeiro, vamos falar,
completar o nosso tratamento de base
hormonal metabólica. Ontem vocês
aprenderam tudo sobre tioide, insulina,
cortisol e hoje a gente vai aprender
tudo sobre sono, intestino e vamos falar
tudo sobre ciclagem, dietas. E claro,
vocês recebem a quarta chave secreta e o
quarto bônus, que é muito especial.
Então, uma breve revisão da nossa
terceira aula de ontem aqui. Primeiro,
base hormonal metabólica.
Base hormonal metabólica. Na base
hormonal metabólica, meninas,
nós falamos sobre a tríade. A maioria de
vocês estão presas nessa tríade
hormonal. Qual que é a tríade? Tireoide,
cortisol e insulina. e tem a conexão
entre eles. Então, se você tem só
problema na tireoide, você passa a ter
problema de insulina e cortisol e uma
coisa vai puxando a outra. [roncando] E
você entendeu toda essa conexão hormonal
e você recebeu ontem a terceira chave
secreta, que foi um e-book de base
hormonal metabólica. Então, vamos lá.
Chaves secretas liberadas aqui para
vocês que fazem parte desse diagnóstico.
Fazem parte desse diagnóstico.
Mapa do emagrecimento que vocês
receberam na primeira aula. Vocês
descobriram a relação do seu perfil
hormonal. do estado de saúde, de acordo
com a sua pontuação do mapa. Então você
descobriu que você ou é perfil
sentinela, ou você tá refém, ou
sobrecarregada, ou prisioneira,
dependendo do estado de saúde. Mas saber
que sua saúde estava ruim, você já
sabia. Vamos ser muito sincero. Uma
pessoa que vive cheia de dores, não
dorme bem, cansaço, é fraca, que de
cabelo, metabolismo lento, preguiça,
desânimo, barriga, efeito sanfona, você
tem alteração de glicose, colesterol,
pressão, toma remédio para dormir,
antidepressivo, anciolítico, você vive
irritada, sem paciência, você acha que
sua saúde tá boa? É, é assim, é, é uma
pergunta muito simples que esclarece
muito sobre você. Agora você consegue
enxergar. Só que você tava tão
acostumado a sentir tudo isso que você
não enxergava antes. Eu te entreguei
também, eu te revelei a relação de cada
um dos problemas do seu mapa com os
hormônios e agora você tem um
diagnóstico em cima do seu radar de
problemas e te entreguei ontem a nossa
nosso e-book de base de hormona
metabólica com tudo que você aprendeu
ontem. Mas eu quero agradecer vocês pelo
comprometimento, pelo engajamento,
porque isso aqui faz parte do nosso
propósito, pelas milhares de
visualizações na nossa terceira aula de
ontem. Então isso mostra que vocês não
só querem aprender sobre saúde, mas
realmente estão com vontade de fazer
diferente, de construir de uma forma
diferente. E o comprometimento de vocês
no nosso post das hashtags, lembrando
que isso aqui conta pontos na hora da
gente escolher a campeã do concurso que
tá rolando dessa semana e vocês foram
lá, eu não tenho culpa. Olha o poder
disso, você contar para mim que você não
tem culpa. Olha, torne, eu não tenho
culpa. A aula foi perfeita. Agora eu
entendo. Foi em todos os
endocrinologistas que eu fui só
indicavam canetas. Olha ali o primeiro
depoimento. Todos os endocrinologistas
que eu fui só me indicavam caneta
emagrecedora. Aí você chora, você ela
chorava, ficava triste porque você não
queria esse caminho e você entende que
você não tem culpa.
E assim foram milhares de depoimentos de
vocês. Muito obrigado cada uma de vocês
que foi lá, se disponibilizou a contar
sua história, contar tudo que aconteceu,
a contar o que tá aprendendo nessas
nossas aulas, porque isso aqui é o que
dá um gás pra gente aqui, dá um gás pra
gente trazer cada vez coisas novas,
melhores para cada uma de vocês. E eu
quero agora mostrar para vocês uma coisa
que é o seguinte, é um vídeo rapidinho
do que acontece quando você trata essa
tríade hormonal.
Então eu sei que você chega aqui, ah,
mas já tentei de tudo, será que isso
aqui vai ser diferente? Não é uma
questão de ser diferente. Todo
emagrecimento deveria ser construído
dessa forma, mas infelizmente não é. Eu
quero te mostrar o que que acontece
quando a gente faz um tratamento
completo de base hormonal metabólica com
ciclagem de dietas e o resultado do que
acontece mesmo em pessoas que já
tentaram, realmente já tentaram quase de
tudo. Eu quero te mostrar a história da
Ana Paula. É um vídeo rapidinho, porque
isso daqui vai conectar com muita de
vocês, porque ela estava na mesma
situação que a maioria de vocês aqui.
Famosas, caríssimas e ainda assim eles
não me olhavam com esse olhar que que
você traz aqui no PEF. Eu cheguei a
fazer um acompanhamento com médico,
reposição hormonal e ele me sugeriu
fazer uma dieta hormonal, mas que é
muito radical e eu ganhei de efeito
colateral dessa dieta radical as pedras
na vesícula e perdi minha vesícula.
Então eu gastava muito dinheiro e não
saía do lugar e só ia piorando,
piorando, piorando. E aí eu cheguei
nesse ponto de ter a sensação de que eu
ia explodir. Tava tudo errado. A
sensação é que eu ia ter um treco em
qualquer momento e eu ia bater as botas,
eu não ia saber nem do que, sabe? Eu ia
pra academia, fui pra academia um tempo
atrás, a academia não resolvia. É, as
roupas aumentando de tamanho. Eu já não
tinha roupa para usar, eu já me recusava
a comprar roupa, só que eu tava num
nível que eu já não entrava nem na minha
roupa de gorda. Eu tenho certeza que
muitas meninas chegam aqui assim. é o a
sensação do último suspiro. Se ele que
tá me falando que é especialista nisso,
tem tantos mil resultados, não puder me
ajudar, quem é que vai poder me ajudar?
O acompanhamento que você dá para mim
especificamente é importante. Eu sou uma
pessoa que funciona melhor durante o
acompanhamento do que sozinha. Mas você
ensina a gente a fazer de um jeito que
depois a gente sobrevive. Eu tive o
aniversário do meu filho na sequência.
Eu lembro dele chegando por mim.
adolescente, não é muito de ficar
falando, reparando em mãe, não. Eu
lembro que ele chegou e fez assim: "Mãe,
meu Deus, mas que diferença na sua
cintura." Eu comecei a ver as roupas
voltando a entrar. É, o resultado ele
vem porque o seu corpo entra no eixo e
não porque você tá fazendo coisas
diferentes. Ah, não era obrigatório est
numa academia fazendo exercício para
emagrecer, não. Se você faz as coisas do
jeito que precisam ser feitas, você
consegue emagrecer e depois você vai
conseguir. Eu ti, eu tava com
resistência e insulínica, tava com
cortisol alto, tava com alteração na
tireoide, coisa que os médicos não
falam, sem a vesícula. Então eu tinha
tudo, né, que o fato de conseguir, de,
enfim, conseguir ter um diagnóstico
correto, decente e e ter ali a lista das
fórmulas que você passa, fala: "Olha,
para isso você só é só fazer isso, é só
fazer aquilo". Então, acho que foi o que
mais fez diferença.
>> Isso é emagrecimento saudável. 11 kg 45
dias. Você falou que já chegou a 12 kg
em 50 dias e ao todo foram quantos?
>> Eu acabei por conta do final do ano
ficando em 13 kg.
Olha
isso, né, meninas? Então, assim, vocês
realmente tentam de tudo, chegam aqui
com dúvida, será que vai ser alguma
coisa diferente? Será que eu vou
aprender alguma coisa diferente? Então,
com o caso da Ana Paula, isso fica fica
muito claro, né? Quando a gente olha Ana
Paula, aluna, do PF360, eu quero que
vocês olhem a barriga. Olhem a barriga,
principalmente a barriga dela, né?
[suspirando]
Então, a questão da barriga já ficou
muito claro relacionado à tríade de
ontem. Você tem resistência insulínica e
cortisol. A gordura da barriga tem
receptor para cortisol e receptor para
insulina. Então ela multiplica. Por isso
que você ganha mais barriga,
principalmente depois dos 45 anos de
idade, você cada vez ganha mais barriga.
Então como que a gente faz para perder
barriga? Controlando cortisol,
controlando insulina e claro, todas as
estratégias ciclagem dietas. Vocês vão
aprender hoje como que tudo isso
funciona.
E foram 10 kg em 45 dias. Uma pessoa que
não conseguia perder peso, tá? Então
assim, eu quero que vocês entendam,
não é milagre, hum, é basicamente uma
construção da saúde de dentro para fora,
sem precisar de remédio, sem precisar de
cirurgia.
E é isso que a gente tá construindo
aqui, essa base do conhecimento, para
que você consiga emagrecer todos os
quilos que você quiser. E essa
estratégia de jejum que a gente tá
fazendo nessa semana, ela passa por
vários momentos de tratamento de base
hormonal metabólica. Então, nessa
estratégia de jejum que vocês estão
fazendo hoje, vocês vão bater 18 horas.
Quem aqui tá preparada para 18 horas,
hein, meninas? Quem aqui tá preparada
para 18 horas,
hein?
Olha que legal. Alguém falou aqui do
chá, tava passando aqui. O chá foi
ótimo, dormi a noite toda. Muito bom. É
isso. É isso que eu quero, gente. Dá
conhecimento que realmente conhecimento
e estratégias que façam sentido para
vocês aqui. Agora [roncando] olha só, a
estratégia jun que vocês estão fazendo
hoje, vocês vão bater 18 horas. É isso
aí. Vamos lá, gente. Tem gente, meu
Deus, tô inseguro, tô com medo. Não,
gente, que quem fez 16 horas tira 18
horas de letra, vai ser tranquilo, vai
conseguir.
Estratégias aqui para esse jejum. Vamos
lá. Estratégias aqui para esse jejum.
Mas antes de falar de estratégias para
esse jejum, eu tenho algumas dúvidas de
vocês. Dr. Renan, tô perdendo massa
magra com jejum. Gente, não, não tem
como você perder massa magra em uma
semana, mesmo porque vocês provavelmente
estão comendo mais proteína do que vocês
comiam antes. O jejum causa gastrite?
Não. Muito pelo contrário. Você que tem
gastrite, quando você fica hora sem se
alimentar, [roncando] a dá tempo do seu
estômago, digamos, desinflamar, porque a
maioria das causas da do de quem tem
gastrite, das pessoas que tm gastrite,
não é por excesso de acidez. Você acha
que é por excesso de acidez, mas não é
por falta de acidez. Como assim, Dr.
Renan? Mas eu sinto queimando tudo.
Exatamente. O seu estômago, ele foi
feito para suportar a acidez. Ele foi
feito para suportar a acidez. Então,
quando você tem falta de acidez e você
come alguma coisa, essa comida irrita a
parede do estômago e pode ir causando
essas lesões.
Sim, por isso que chá de espinheira
santa, para quem tem gastrite,
esofagite, refluxo, é excepcional. Chá
de espinheira santa funciona como é
prazol natural. Você pode tomar de manhã
e de noite, mas o torre não, jejum tira
a energia, vai causar uma fraqueza?
Não. Vamos lá. Nos primeiros dias, em
quem tem resistência à insulina, você
pode ficar um pouquinho mais cansada,
mas a partir de hoje vocês vão ver que
melhora energia, melhora disposição a
partir desse jejum mais prolongado,
porque seu corpo já se adaptou, já está
se adaptando ao processo. O jejum vai
atrasar o meu metabolismo? Não. Muito
pelo contrário, com o jejum. melhor a
função de fígado. Você já aprendeu a
relação do fígado com os hormônios da
tireoide e o seu corpo começa a utilizar
gordura como fonte de energia. Agora o
jejum é melhor fazer de manhã ou de
noite? Porque tem gente que gosta de
fazer o jejum invertido. Você pode fazer
o jejum invertido. O que que é o jejum
invertido? Você faz a sua última
refeição do dia 3, 4 da tarde e você vai
direto pro café da manhã, porque tem
gente que não gosta de pular o café da
manhã. E se você não gosta de pular o
café da manhã, você pode fazer esse
jejum invertido sem nenhum problema.
Posso usar doçante no jejum? Pode
stévia, principalmente stévia.
Agora vocês entra no nosso jejum de 18
horas. Vamos lá. O que que acontece no
seu corpo num jejum de 18 horas?
Insulina cai. Insulina cai. Insulina
caiu. A gente cria um ambiente perfeito
para você perder barriga, para você
perder medidas, para você queimar
gordura. Então, vai ativar ainda mais o
processo de queima de gordura. e começa
a ativar de uma forma melhor um processo
que chama turnover celular. Que que é
turnover celular? Troca de células
velhas por células novas. É como se o
corpo renovasse de uma forma mais
eficiente. Então, sintomas que vocês
podem ter, pode sentir às vezes uma
tonturinha, cabeça um pouquinho pesada,
mas qual que é o segredo desse jejum?
Muita água no período de jejum e
pitadinha de sal em pelo menos três
copos de água. Pitadinha de sal
integral. Isso vai trazer um bem-estar
no período de jejum. Se você sentir
fome, pode comprar, pode consumir o
psílium, pode colocar uma colher de sopa
de psílium num copo de água, porque o
psílio é uma fibra, vai te dar uma
sensação de saciedade. Uma outra coisa
muito legal, água com gás. Se você
sentir um pouquinho de fome, água com
gás, gente, água com gás, o gás dilata o
estômago e ajuda nesse controle do
apetite. Pode utilizar água com gás sem
nenhum problema.
>> [roncando]
>> E você começa a desinchar e o seu corpo
começa a utilizar estoque de glicose que
tem no fígado como fonte de energia.
Então você que tem gordura no fígado, é
excepcional a estratégia de jejum quando
bem quando bem utilizada, quando bem
empregada. Então eu quero que vocês
tenham muita atenção. Por quê? Porque
amanhã é o segundo dia de jejum de 18
horas. Vocês já sabem onde encontrar na
plataforma, vocês já estão aplicando a
dieta de vocês e estratégia para vencer
o jejum, cílium, água com gás, quem
quiser comprar, adquirir o glucomano,
mas não precisa, pode serum, você acha
em qualquer supermercado. E posso
consumir alguma gordura nesse jejum?
Óleo de coco no café, azeite? Não pode
nesse jejum não. No jejum de 20 horas
até OK, até a gente pode introduzir.
Sim, entendido, meninas?
Entendidos? Gente, período de jejum, já
falei isso para vocês algumas vezes. Não
é para consumir canela, não é para
consumir cravo, nem própolis, nem água
com limão em jejum. Não é para consumir,
combinados? Nesse jejum não. Então, tema
da nossa aula de hoje, base, eixo,
intestino, sono. Então, ontem vocês
aprenderam a tríade hormonal, tireoide,
cortisol, insulina. Hoje a gente vai
aprender tudo sobre o eixo intestino e
sono e tudo sobre ciclagem de dietas,
que é o nosso segundo pilar do sucesso
do emagrecimento. Quais são os três
pilares? Mente, mentalidade, ciclagem de
dietas e base hormonal metabólica.
Então, hoje vocês vão aprender tudo
sobre o nosso segundo pilar, que é
ciclagem de dietas. Vamos lá, então.
Então, ontem falamos sobre insulina,
tireide, cortisol. Hoje a gente vai
falar tudo sobre intestino e sono. Quem
aqui dorme mal, quem que tem intestino
preso? Coloca aqui nos comentários para
mim que eu quero saber. Alguém aqui?
Quem aqui? Ei, meninas, quem que dorme
mal? Quem temo preso?
Gente, alguém tá falando aqui sobre
receber dieta, gente, da área de
membros. As dietas estão dentro da área
de membros e lá vocês não abriram os
materiais. Então, dentro da área de
membros tem lá. Se você não preencheu o
seu rastreamento para receber seu
pré-diagnóstico médico, tem lá como
escolher minha dieta. E tem acesso às
dietas. Tem uma coisa que eu não consigo
fazer que é sua parte. Se você nem entra
na área de membros, então fica um pouco
complicado porque os materiais incríveis
lá para vocês. Mas vamos lá. Eixo
metabólico, sono, intestino. Quero te
fazer algumas perguntas aqui. Você
acorda de madrugada? Acorda mais de duas
vezes à noite para orinar?
Você acorda de manhã cansada mesmo
dormindo bem?
Você é uma pessoa que dorme com remédio
e você tem intestino preso ou intestino
solto? Você tem gases, barriga
distendida e você não sabe o que que
causa distensão abdominal. Se você tem
um desses problemas aqui, um desses
desses dessas respondeu sim para uma
dessas perguntas, você tem alteração no
eixo sono intestino. Então vamos lá.
Qual que é seu tipo de feses?
Tipo um, tipo dois, tipo três, tipo
quatro, tipo 5? Qual o seu tipo de
fezes? É bolinha? É ressecado que chega
a machucar?
ou é o cocozinho felizinho ali,
o perfeito seria você ser o tipo três ou
tipo quatro de intestino. E vamos
entender aqui quais as causas. Se você
tem o cocozinho de cabrito, que é de
bolinha, isso significa que você tem
baixa ingestão de fibras, baixa
hidratação ou você tem algum problema de
movimento intestinal? Vamos deixar claro
uma coisa aqui. Muitas de vocês acham
que o seu intestino preso é por causa de
genética, é por causa de algum problema
que você tem, mas não. Alteração de
intestino genético corresponde só a 5%
dos casos. 5% das pessoas no planeta que
tem intestino preso é por conta de algum
problema genético ou alguma doença
intestinal ou seu intestino não
movimenta muito bem. Só 5%. Então,
provavelmente você não está,
provavelmente você não está nesse tipo,
nesse, nessa causa.
Só que vocês acham que comem fibra,
vocês acham que bebem água e não bebem.
Então, imagino que todos vocês já estão
implementando hidratação de forma
eficiente, principalmente tentando beber
aqui, ó, uns 500 ml de água. Tentando
beber aqui, ó, uns 500 ml de água a cada
2 horas.
O segundo tipo que é o cocô, as fezes
mais ressecadas
tem relação com desidratação e também
fibra. E claro, se você tiver algum
outro problema intestinal, alguma doença
intestinal que é mais raro, o perfeito
seria o tipo quatro, ok? Tipo três, tipo
quatro, perfeito. E o último tipo é você
que tem mais diarreia, feeses
amolecidas. Esse quadro tem relação ou
com infecções
ou com intolerâncias e alergias
alimentares,
mas pode ser síndrome do intestino
irritável,
estress,
você que é uma pessoa muito ansiosa.
Portanto, cada tipo de feeses, um, dois
ou cinco, elas têm causas diferentes.
Mas vamos entender aqui. Você que tem
intestino preso e você que às vezes nem
tem intestino preso, mas tem gases de
extensão abdominal. Gente, tira print
dessa tela aqui. Tira print você que tem
intestino preso, porque isso aqui vale
ouro. Tira print dessa tela.
O que que causa? Qual a principal causa
de intestino preso? Vamos lá. Qual a
principal causa de intestino preso?
A principal causa de intestino preso não
é baixo consumo de água e não é baixo
consumo de fibra.
Não é a principal causa do intestino
preso é gases. Como assim, Dr. Renan?
Gases. Sim. [risadas]
A principal causa de intestino preso é
gases. Vamos aqui. Vamos só para você
entender.
O intestino tá aqui e aí ele faz esse
movimento que se chama movimento
peristáltico para empurrar o quê? As
feeses para serem eliminadas. Ele faz
esse movimento e vai empurrando, faz
isso aqui. Só que quando você consome
algum alimento que produz gases, você
que tem a barriga distendida, você que
tem gases, você que tem extensão
abdominal, você consome o agulhimento
que produz gases, seu intestino é assim.
Quando produz gases, você tem a ilusão
que o o os gases estão no seu estômago.
Não. Quando sua barriga distende, os
gases estão no seu intestino. Então, o
que que acontece com os gases? Um
alimento que fermenta muito, vai lá e
fermentou, produz gases. E aí o que
acontece com a alça do intestino?
Dilata. E quando dilata, sabe o que que
seu corpo? Gente, o nosso corpo é uma
máquina incrível, é perfeito, né?
Essa alça do intestino dilata, o seu
intestino paralisa pro mecanismo de
autoproteção, porque o seu corpo sabe
que quando produziu gás, dilatou o seu
intestino, corre o risco de quê? Do seu
intestino estourar. Então, se ele
continua movimentando mesmo inchado
cheio de gases, corre risco de romper,
de estourar mesmo. Então, toda vez que
você come alguma coisa que produz muito
gases, que fermenta muito, o seu
intestino dilata e aí que que ele faz?
Paralisa.
Portanto, você que tem intestino preso e
você tem gases abdominais,
não é porque você tá consumindo pouca
água. Pode até ser que você esteja
consumindo pouca água ou pouca fibra,
mas a principal causa do seu intestino
preso é porque ele está paralisado
devido a gases. E quais são os alimentos
que mais produzem gases?
Esses aqui são alimentos, essa tabelinha
aqui, ó, tabela de alimentos alto em FOD
Maps. São alimentos que fermentam muito.
São alimentos que fermentam muito.
Então, olha isso daqui. Eu não tô
falando só sobre alimentos que não são
saudáveis, eu tô falando sobre alimentos
saudáveis.
Então você come alguma coisa que estufa
sua barriga e você não sabe e você não
sabe, por exemplo, alho e cebola. A
comida nossa aqui no Brasil, do
brasileiro, tudo tem alho e cebola,
gente. Alho e cebola é rico em Fodmaps.
Fermenta muito. Fermenta muito alho,
principalmente aquele miolinho do alho.
Você então que tem distensão abdominal e
não sabe o que que é que você comeu,
você tem que começar a fazer o teste de
retirar alguns alimentos. Precisa
retirar todos? Não, porque você não vai
ter problema com todos, mas quando a
barriga estender, você vai ter que ver o
que que você comeu e vir nessa tabela.
Olha só, maçã fermenta muito.
manga, melancia,
alho, cebola, couve e flor, brócolis,
cogumelos,
mandioca em excesso, batata doce em
grandes quantidades,
feijão, lentilha, grão de bico,
derivados de leite, todos,
castanha do caju, castanha de caju,
pistachi,
alguns adoçantes como o sorbitol,
maltitol, chilitol, eritritol.
Então assim, agora que você entende isso
sobre gases, sobre gases, você pera aí,
então existe uma outra causa que é mais
importante do que água e fibra pro meu
intestino prender.
Depois, claro, vem água, fibra, alguma
má formação do seu intestino, que são
casos muito raros, má formação, algum
problema genético intestinal, mas talvez
você coma uma alimentação saudável que
fermenta muito, então produziu gases, o
seu intestino paralisa. Claro,
entendido? Isso daqui tirou print,
gente. Quem aqui tem provavelmente tirou
print dessa tela?
Se você depois também, ah, Renan, não,
não tirei print. Se você jogar no Google
aí na internet, você acha essa tabela,
você consegue achar. Coloca lá, tabela
de alimentos FOD MAP. F O D M FOD MAP.
E qual a relação do seu intestino com
ganho de peso total?
Porque dentro do seu intestino, é no
intestino que a gente produz a
serotonina. Serotonina é o
neurotransmissor da felicidade. Sabe
esse antidepressivo que vocês utilizam?
Todo antidepressivo antiolítico que
vocês usam, que que eles fazem? Eles
fazem a serotonina, que é o
neurotransmissor da felicidade, ficar
disponível no seu corpo. Só que que
adianta você utilizar o antidepressivo
se intestino não funciona? Porque 90% da
serotonina é produzida no intestino. E
se a sua serotonina cai quando o
intestino é preso ou doente, você fica
mais deprimida, irritada, sem paciência,
compulsiva, quer comer mais.
Se seu intestino é doente, a imunidade
cai, porque dentro do intestino nós
temos a microbiota intestinal. E essa
microbiota, que são as bactérias
benéficas, claro, tem outros componentes
que não são bactérias, mas maioria
bactérias, trabalham pra gente, pra sua
imunidade, pra sua saúde, pra sua
longevidade, pra sua proteção. E quando
você tem intestino doente, você começa a
ter uma desregulação dessa microbiota.
E se você tem intestino doente, diminui
a conversão dos hormônios da tireoide. E
sabe as canetinhas emagrecedoras aqui,
ó, que trabalham no GLP1?
O GLP1 é o hormônio intestinal que
controla a sua saciedade, o metabolismo
de glicose, de insulina. Se você tem
intestino doente, você altera insulina,
perfil de glicose mais fome.
Então você às vezes quer usar uma
canetinha que tá trabalhando nesse
hormônio intestinal. Só que quando você
para, essas canetinhas muitas das vezes
prendem seu intestino e quando você
para, volta a fome, volta compulsão,
altera o perfil de glicose, você engorda
tudo de novo. Se eu posso então melhorar
a saúde do seu intestino para você ter
um auto controle sem precisar de
medicação, é isso que eu tenho que
fazer. E seu intestino falha, vai
prejudicar o seu humor, seu sono, a sua
tireoide, cortisol, estrogênio. Porque o
intestino ele é diretamente,
energeticamente conectado à saúde
cerebral por conta dessa serotonina. Por
isso muita gente fala que o intestino é
o segundo cérebro e realmente é porque
tudo começa por ali. Se você tem um
intestino ruim, seu sono altera. Se você
tem um sono ruim, o seu intestino
altera. Eles são conectados. Esse eixo
intestino sono e aí você engorda, você
entra no mecanismo metabólico que você
não controla. Lembra que eu falei para
vocês? A culpa não é sua. Você não
escolheu tentino preso. Você não
escolheu dormir mal. E você não consegue
controlar o ganho de peso quando você
tem esses dois problemas. você não
consegue controlar seu emocional, seu
estress quando você tem intestino preso,
alteração de sono. Então esse eixo ele
tem que ser muito bem alinhado para você
ter uma saúde mais plena, para você ter
um autocontrole, para você ficar bem,
para você ficar feliz. E isso a gente
precisa controlar aqui. Então quero que
vocês olhem essa foto aqui. [roncando]
Vocês acham que comem fibra, mas não
comem. Olha só, se você pegar um pratão
de salada de alface, tomate e você
falar: "Ah, eu como fibra todo dia". Um
prato de salada desse tem em torno de
1,3 g de fibra.
E você precisa, sabe de quanto num dia?
De 30 a 40 g de fibra. Para ter o
intestino que funciona.
Você precisa de 30 a 40 g de fibra
todo dia.
Então, se você come só um prato disso
aqui de salada, você não tá comendo nada
de fibra. Por isso que intestino prende.
Agora, olha lá, quando você coloca
sementes, grãos, leguminosas,
fibras, como
o próprio psílium,
chia, linhaça,
aí você consegue bater as 30 g de fibra.
Tá vendo a diferença disso aqui?
Tá vendo a diferença disso?
Agora vamos lá. Tira print disso aqui,
que isso aqui também vale ouro para
vocês. Quais as principais fontes de
fibra em uma colher de sobremesa? Ó, uma
colher de sobremesa rasa de chia vai ter
3.4 g de fibra.
Linhaça 2.8. Olha lá o psílium. Uma
colher sobremesa vai ter 5 g de fibra.
5 g de fibra.
No período de jejum. Sóps psílium. No
período de hoje, um sol psílium,
ok? As outras não, porque as outras chia
tem uma caloria, a linhaça tem caloria,
o psílium, somente psílium, ok? Agora
olha aqui, ó. Farelo de aveia, farelo de
trigo, farinha de coco, farinha de maçã.
Assim você consegue fazer um mix no seu
dia e conseguir introduzir a quantidade
de fibras que você precisa.
Entendido?
Ah, mas eu não consigo introduzir essas
fibras. Existem hoje em dia algumas
fibras em em pó que você compra e
mistura com água. É uma opção que você
pode utilizar.
Então, como tratar o seu intestino?
Gente, esse slide vale 10 vezes o que
vocês investiram para est aqui. Esse
slide vale umas 10 vezes o que vocês
investiram para est aqui. Como tratar?
Primeiro, aplica as téc cinco técnicas
da água que vocês têm de material.
retira os alimentos alto em FOD Maps
para controlar gases, senão o intestino
paralisa. Essa fórmula de probiótico
ajuda no intestino, ajuda na compulsão
alimentar e ajuda até no metabolismo e
ajuda até a diminuir vontade de doce.
Essa fórmula de probiótico. Chá de cene
pode muito de vez em quando, porque ele
causa disbiose intestinal, não pode
utilizar sempre. Laxante pode, não é
recomendado, porque o laxante também vai
alterar e deixar a sua microbiota
intestinal doente. E quais os alimentos
que mais ajudam no intestino? Anota isso
que eu vou falar agora. Quais as frutas
que mais ajudam no intestino?
Quais ajuda a que mais ajuda no
intestino?
Mamão,
amexa, ki é fantástico para intestino.
Se você consumir um ki à noite, ajuda no
sono e no intestino.
Abacate,
morango,
abacaxi. Vou repetir. Vou repetir.
mamão, amexa, kiwi, abacate, morango,
abacaxi e tem o figo, que é muito legal
também para intestino. E claro, tem
outros alimentos fermentados, né, como o
caso de de que tem que tem probióticos,
mas vamos lá. Alimentos grave, isso que
eu vou falar agora.
Só [roncando] probiótico não faz
intestino funcionar. Então, não adianta
você só querer tomar kefir com bucha,
não vai fazer funcional. Você precisa de
hidratação, precisa de fibra e precisa
controlar a fermentação, precisa
controlar gases.
Agora você que tem alguma doença
intestinal, ah, tem síndrome intestino
irritável, tem alguma inflamação
intestinal, quais suplementos para
intestino? E tem um suplemento para
intestino, desculpa antes de eu falar
isso, que é o magnésio citrato. O
citrato de magnésio ou magnésio citrato
é um tipo de magnésio que faz o
intestino funcionar. magnésio citrato aí
a dose varia de 300 até um 300 mg até 2
g, dependendo do caso. E qual o
suplemento para desinflamar parede de
intestino?
Qual o suplemento para desinflamar
parede de intestino? Glutamina,
zincocarnosina.
Fantástico, viu? Existem algumas
pessoas, talvez t diverticulite, que é
uma doença inflamatória intestino que
tem os buraquinhos. Aí, nesse caso, as
sementes em si, não recomendo que você
utilize as sementes pequenas, você usa a
farinha das sementes. A farinha das
sementes, mas principalmente você que
tem diverticulite, alguma outra doença
inflamatória, tem que usar citrato de
magnésio, glutamina e zinco carnosina
para desinflamar a parigem intestinal.
Agora vamos falar sobre sono. Quem aqui
dorme mal? Vamos falar sobre sono,
gente. Bom, vocês então agora t um
tratamento de intestino
completo, tratamento completaço de
intestino, informações direcionadas, sem
enrolação, para vocês terem estratégias
a serem aplicadas. É isso que eu quero
passar aqui para vocês, o nosso desafio,
viu?
O Psílium pode durante o jejum. Psílium
não vai quebrar o jejum de vocês,
inclusive ajudar controle de fome.
Quem é que acorda de madrugada? Se você
acorda entre 1 e 3 da manhã, presta
atenção nisso aqui, que legal. Se você é
uma pessoa que acorda muito entre 1 e 3
da manhã, tem relação com o meridiano
energético do fígado. Significa que seu
fígado está sobrecarregado.
O fígado é um órgão que trabalha de
madrugada. Então, se você acorda mais de
duas vezes à noite para urinar, é o seu
fígado que tá doente, tá sobrecarregado,
tá fazendo muita força para trabalhar.
Se você é uma pessoa que acorda entre 3
e 5 da manhã, é o meridiano do pulmão.
Pela medicina chinesa, o pulmão ele tá
ligado a baixa de energia, baixa de
vitalidade e a tristeza. Então, uma
pessoa que tem baixa energia, baixa
vitalidade, normalmente tem um
comprometimento desse meridiano
pulmonar, acorda, acorda mais entre 3 e
5 da manhã. Se você é uma pessoa que que
desperta muito entre 5 e 7 da manhã, eu
sei que algumas pessoas acordam antes
disso, então a gente perde um pouco o
parâmetro para essas pessoas. Tem
relação com eliminação, que é o
meridiano energético do intestino
grosso. É a hora natural da eliminação.
Então, quem tem intestino preso
normalmente desperta muito nesse horário
aqui. Você que tem alguma alteração de
intestino, ah, tô acordo todo a noite
inteira. Então, talvez você tenha um um
comprometimento de saúde um pouquinho
maior, mas tudo tem tratamento. Qual a
relação do sono no emagrecimento?
Meninas, prestem atenção nisso daqui.
Qual a relação do sono com seu
emagrecimento?
Primeiro, é durante o ciclo do sono que
você regula cortisol, regula hormônios
sexuais, que você limpa seu cérebro, que
você, claro, descansa, que você vai
desinchar, que o seu fígado funciona
para filtrar tudo. Se você é uma pessoa
que dorme mal, cortisol fica alterado,
seu fígado não funciona bem, você vai
ficar mais inchada, o seu cérebro não
vai limpar as toxinas do dia.
Então você chega para mim e fala assim:
"Doutor Renan, minha memória é ruim. Eu
sou uma pessoa ansiosa, estressada, sem
paciência, compulsiva, não consigo
emagrecer, mesmo comendo pouco, sou uma
pessoa cansada. Aí você acha que eu
preciso passar para você um suplemento
para energia, um suplemento pra memória,
um suplemento para pr para humor, pra
ansiedade, pro seu metabolismo? Só que
não, eu só preciso regular o sono. O
sono é a principal chave regulatória de
todo o seu metabolismo. Se você dorme
mal, você tem mais eh você tem mais
resistência insulínica, altera seu
cortisol, você ganha mais barriga, não
converte adequadamente os hormônios da
tireoide e seu fígado não funciona.
Então, quer começar a melhorar tudo?
Começa pelo sono.
Ah, eu quero melhorar um pouquinho de
tudo. Tô melhora o sono se você dorme
mal.
Aí você que dorme mal, GH, que é
hormônio do crescimento, não produz
direito. Hormônios sexuais também não.
Aí você fala: "Nossa, minha libido é
baixa, eu tô perdendo massa magra, eu tô
com a unha fraca, tô com o cabelo
caindo". Porque para você ter uma
vitalidade, para você construir coisas
no seu corpo, construir no seguinte, no
seguinte sentido: de construir músculo,
de proteger osso, eu preciso do GH, eu
preciso dos hormônios sexuais. Então, se
o sono, se o seu sono falha, você vai
ter mais fome, menos saciedade, de
segura, o seu metabolismo, altera seu
cortisol. Então você entra num ciclo
aqui hormonal que você não controla.
Deixa eu te perguntar, quem é que
escolheu dormir mal?
Quem é que escolheu dormir mal?
Olha que legal, tem gente que já tá indo
dormir melhor aqui, ó. porque tá indo
mais cedo, dormir mais cedo para acordar
cedo. É isso.
É isso. E claro que existem algumas
situações particulares aqui de pessoas
quem tá amamentando. Se você tá
amamentando, é uma realidade que você
vai viver por um período breve. Então
não se preocupa com isso. Você consegue
emagrecer
mesmo você acordando de noite para
amamentar. Claro que com a amamentação a
velocidade de emagrecimento é um
pouquinho mais lenta, mas é uma
realidade que, ok, tá tudo certo, uma
realidade que você tá vivendo agora.
E curta esse momento, porque vai passar
muito rápido. Eu sei que é cansativo,
né? Mas curta esse momento.
Como então melhorar sono? Tira print
dessa tela. Vamos lá. Tira print. Isso
aqui,
antes de pensar em usar melatonina, que
muita gente fala que é o hormônio do
sono, antes de usar melatonina, gente,
blend de magnésios, magnésio treonato
com magnésioglicina.
Magnésio treonato de 200 a 500 mg,
magnésioglicina de 200 a 500 mg.
Esse esse blend de magnésio causa um
relaxamento cerebral, ajuda na memória e
vai ajudar você a dormir melhor. E tem
um chás, o chá de mulungu com camomila,
uma colher de sopa de mulungu, uma
colher de sopa de camomila, chazinho à
noite. E aí, claro, tem todas as
técnicas pra higiene do sono, que
podem parecer bobeira, mas são
excepcionais para melhorar a qualidade
do seu sono. Primeiro, evita luz azul.
Seu celular, gente, hoje em dia todo
celular tem o bloqueio de luz azul. Você
consegue aí, pede alguém para te ajudar.
Depois das 6 da tarde, dá para você
ativar isso automático. Ele sozinho faz
isso. O meu todo dia, depois das 6 da
tarde, das 18 horas,
ele ativa a luz, o bloqueio de luz azul
automático. Isso já vai te ajudar. Se
você é uma pessoa muito ansiosa, você
precisa ter um livro, um livro qualquer,
e você lê antes de dormir umas quatro
páginas de um livro, porque assim você
vai desconectar o seu cérebro de tudo
que aconteceu no dia. Deitou, faz a
técnica de respiração, 456. Puxa o ar em
4 segundos, segura por cinco, solta em
seis. Faz isso umas 10 vezes, vai causar
um relaxamento profundo. E quando você
acordar,
exposição a luz do dia, vai pra janela
da sua casa, não precisa ser o sol, a
luz do dia. Fica ali uns 10 minutinhos
tomando seu café, vai lá, me assiste com
a luz do dia batendo no seu olho e isso
ativa o relógio biológico do hipotálamo.
Coisas básicas que realmente funcionam.
Então, qual a relação do eixo sono
intestino? Eles são os guardiões do seu
metabolismo. Se seu sono tá ruim, a
melatonina, que é o hormônio natural do
sono, cai. Você, mulher, que está na
pré-menopausa ou pós-menopausa, por que
que o sono piora? Porque a melatonina
passa a ter uma baixa produção nessa
fase. Por isso que você começa a dormir
mal. Se você é uma pessoa pós-menopausa,
que dorme muito mal, uma dose pitinha de
melatonina pode te ajudar nesse estímulo
cerebral. Dose de 0,25. É dose pequena
mesmo. Não é para te sedar, não é para
te apagar, é só pro seu cérebro entender
que a melatonina chegou. Só que nessa
fase pré-menopausa, pós-menopausa, sua
melatonina cai, ela fica baixa.
Portanto, melatonina cai. Quando você
dorme mal, cortisol altera, seu
intestino fica mais inflamado,
disbiose intestinal altera, microbiota
intestinal, cai serotonina, você fica
mais deprimida, mais irritada, mais
ansiosa, piora o sono, porque pro seu
sono tá legal, você tem que ter uma
produção de serotonina legal. Essa é a
conexão só no intestino. O sono produz a
serotonina, desculpa, o intestino produz
90% da serotonina. E para você dormir
bem, você tem que ter produzido
serotonina no dia. Então você entra num
ciclo vicioso de intestino sono,
intestino sono, intestino sono. E o seu
intestino pode até funcionar, pode até
funcionar.
Isso não quer dizer que ele é saudável.
Claro, porque pode ser que você tenha um
intestino inflamado, uma disbiose
intestinal que faz com que você tenha
uma desregulação desse ciclo, mesmo
intestino funcionando. E quantas vezes é
ideal o intestino funcionar? O intestino
não precisa funcionar todo dia. Se você
for pelo menos quatro vezes na semana no
banheiro, ótimo, pelo menos quatro
vezes, isso já não é considerado
intestino preso mais.
Então, quero dizer uma coisa aqui para
você, presta atenção.
Não é você o problema, é o cansaço que
fala por você. Como assim o cansaço que
fala por você? Então eu sei que quando
as coisas apertam aí no seu lado, você
fica estressada, você dá patada nas
pessoas que você mais ama, nos seus
filhos, marido, você sem paciência e
[roncando] você às vezes nem você se
aguenta.
Então
chega uma pessoa e começa a fazer
pergunta repetida para você. Seu marido
chegar, onde que tá a vasilha para
guardar isso? Onde que tá o prato? Onde
que tá a panela? Isso já te ferve o
sangue
porque você tá sensível. Mas isso não é
só emocional. Pode ser, claro, todo
emocional, de traumas, de problemas
pessoais que você tem, mas eu quero
dizer que provavelmente você não é
assim. Você não é essa pessoa estourada.
Sabe por quê? Vamos lá. Deixa eu
desenhar aqui um um dia da sua rotina.
Vê se você consegue se enxergar nisso
aqui. Você vai já acorda cansada
porque a sua noite foi picada. Você
acordou várias vezes à noite, você
acorda pensando nas contas, nos filhos,
no trabalho, no que que você tem que
entregar, num tanto de coisa que você
tem que fazer em casa da da dos seus
pais idosos que provavelmente você tem
que cuidar, que cuidar. E aí de repente
chega no começo do dia, você tem que
entregar sua energia para preparar o
café para sua família, entregar sua
energia para cuidar da sua casa,
entregar sua energia para cuidar da
família, para cuidar do seu trabalho. E
você entrega sua energia o tempo todo.
Aí chega no final do dia, sendo que você
não descansou à noite, você tá com baixa
serotonina porque intestino não
funciona, você tá esgotada.
E daí qualquer pergunta que seu filho te
faz, qualquer pergunta que seu marido te
faz, qualquer tênis que deixam na sala,
uma meia que deixa jogada, isso te faz
explodir,
porque você já esgotou,
já esgotou tudo que tinha para entregar.
Você deu o seu máximo durante o dia.
[roncando]
Então, a culpa de você agir desse jeito
não é sua.
Você consegue enxergar e às vezes você
até se se arrepende do jeito que você
tratou as pessoas que você ama. Mas é
porque você não teve controle, você
simplesmente foi lá expodiu
às vezes por coisa pequena, sabe? Coisa
pouca, bobagem.
Mas você desconta neles não porque você
não gosta deles, não porque você não
quer ficar perto. Às vezes parece que
você não quer ficar perto, mas é porque
você tá no limite do seu ou emocional
causado por esse problema hormonal.
Então eu preciso te explicar que eu vejo
isso em grande maioria das alunas.
E depois que você começa a cuidar da sua
saúde, você tem mais disposição, mais
energia, seu humor melhora, ansiedade
melhora, tudo melhora. Então, não é que
se você tá uma pessoa ruim, uma pessoa
irritada, uma pessoa sem paciência, não
é depressão, não é só ansiedade,
é o hormônio do estress que tá
desregulado por um eixo só no intestino
alterado.
Por isso, tira, tira esse peso, sabe?
Você se cobra demais e te cobram demais.
E aí você sente sobrecarregada?
Então o problema nunca foi a sua falta
de paciência,
foi só noite mal dormida, foi seu
intestino que não funcionou direito.
Então você não precisa de autocontrole
para parar de gritar. Você precisa de
uma noite boa, você precisa de dormir
melhor, você precisa de um tratamento
melhor. Aí volta a paciência,
você volta a se sentir amada. Mas não
que você não fosse amada antes, mas é
porque você tava tão irritada, tão sem
paciência com todo mundo que você não
consegue enxergar isso.
Então, quero te ensinar uma coisa.
Se você tem falta de paciência com as
pessoas que você gosta, não é só
emocional, não é só psicológico.
Pode ser só uma noite mal dormida e aí
você acha que você precisa de um
suplemento para ansiedade, um suplemento
para depressão, um suplemento para
memória.
E não, você só precisa dormir melhor.
Você só precisa dormir um pouco mais.
Você entende a relação com seus
hormônios? E aqui a gente entra no mapa,
né, no nosso radar de problemas
hoje. Então, vocês entenderam um eixo
sono intestino. Só qual que é o problema
do eixo sono? Principalmente se você tem
um sono ruim, piora cortisol, piora
insulina, piora tineroide. [risadas]
E aí você passa a ter todo um
comprometimento desse mapa, do seu radar
de problemas, talvez porque a raiz seja
essa daqui. E é isso que eu quero que
você entenda. A gente precisa analisar e
tratar a sua raiz do problema. E pra
gente começar a tratar sono intestino,
que hoje eu vou liberar a quarta chave
para vocês. A quarta chave secreta.
A nossa quarta chave secreta será
tratamento completo da raiz do problema.
E quem [roncando] tiver na aula hoje
ganha o nosso quarto bônus, mas é para
quem tá ao vivo na aula. E esse quarto
bônus, gente, ele é muito incrível.
Ele é um protocolo para desinchar
rápido,
mas quem tá tiver na aula recebe ao
final. Eu quero te mostrar agora uma
história rapidinho da Gisele, porque a
Gisele tava exatamente com essa questão.
Ela tinha trabalho noturno, ela não
conseguia emagrecer. Muita gente aqui
tem trabalho noturno, muita gente aqui,
inclusive que amamenta, passa por essa
situação. E a Gisele conseguiu
emagrecer. Olha essa história rapidinho
aqui, meninas.
Tentei várias coisas, principalmente uma
tal de uma sopa que eu não posso nem ver
a na minha frente. Fiz durante um tempo,
emagreci 2 kg na época, voltava.
>> Aí tava mais um mês naquela luta, eu não
conseguia nem ver mais a sopa. Depois eu
fiz também a da do Can, não sei se você
já ouviu falar, dieta da do canío,
emagreci 1, kg. Depois disso fiz a dieta
do ovo. Então assim, foram várias, uma
certa vez fui numa nutricionista, aí ela
conseguiu e passei fome. Ela não me deu
nem a tabela dela, não era nem o que o
PF me deu, que tem um monte de
substituição, não era aquela tabelinha
seca ali, né? E eu lembro de 5 meses eu
levei para emagrecer 9 kg início de
junho com você e eliminei 21 kg. O dobro
mais que o dobro. Quando eu peguei meu
estádio de exame, eh, eu trabalho na
área da saúde também, sou técnico de
enfermagem e eu levei pra minha médica
lá uma clínica, né, que é amiga minha,
ela olhou, falou só tiroide é um
pouquinho alterada, mas ela não mexe com
essa parte de, né, de de emagrecimento,
tal. Aí eu marquei uma endócrina. Aí ela
olhou e falou: "Sua tiroide tá ótima".
Falei: "Meu Deus". E agora foi, vou
acreditar no barbudi. Eu bem assim,
[risadas]
aí cheguei em casa, foi com meu marido,
falei assim, eu queria, eu acho que eu
vou fazer o programa dele. Agradeço
muito a Deus pela sua vida. Eu tô, eu tô
me sentindo uma mulher mais feliz. Sabe
por quê? Os outros que você olhava para
mim, me via assim, né? Se me chamar de
gordinha, eu já tava, mas agora eu tô
sendo chamar de magrela. Ai, não
acredito que eu tô ouvindo isso.
>> Cabelo caindo, tava
>> cabelo caindo, tudo. E aí a gente foi,
cuidou de você, você acreditou. For um,
se eu não me engano, 12 kg
>> em 45 dias.
>> 12 a 13 kg
>> em 45 dias. Você imaginou que você tem
um resultado desse Zé? Você imaginou que
você
>> Olha só. Nossa, eu tenho vergonha de
olhar essa foto minha. [risadas]
>> Olha a diferença da barriga,
>> Dra. Eh, eu tenho até mais uma boa
notícia para te dar e comentei com ela e
falei que você tinha tomado remédio da
tireóide. Eu não tinha problema, mas era
subclínica que você tinha me explicado
na devolutiva e eu tava com testino
preso e você tinha passado também de
ansiedade, de tudo. Você me tratou, né?
Você tratou um conjunto, não foi? Você
me tratou de dentro para fora, posso
falar assim, né? E olha, eh, eu tinha
descoberto através de você sobre você tá
falando agorinha, essas berruguinha na
no pescoço. E eu olhava e falava:
"Gente, eu tenho resistência ulínica".
Porque ele fala que isso é resistência
insulino. Eu tinha tirado uma vez, mas
falou que era estética. Se era só tirar,
mas que ia voltar, mas nunca me explicou
que era resistência insulínica. E aí e
eu estava tomando glifagem quando eu
comecei o seu programa e eu tive nessa
mesma endócrina, ela passou para mim de
amicron também no almoço e glifagem à
noite. E aí eu fui fazer toda a dieta
que você falou, cortei o, primeira
coisa, cortei trigo, mas cortei errado
antes do seu programa. Cortei uma semana
antes do seu programa. Foi por isso que
eu falo que você veio na hora certa,
porque eu meti a cara sabe de quê? Nas
tapioca da vida, [risadas] achando que
eu tava bacana
>> armadilha
>> e não era. Eu cortei o carboidrato de
vez, não podia. Eu falava tudo que eu
debaixo da terra eu não como. E você
veio me ensinando que não tinha nada a
ver aquilo
>> e que podia comer carboidrato bom.
>> Que podia comer, só que o carboidrato
bom, né? Quando eu fiz o detox, a minha
glicose chegou a 66 remédio, né?
>> Aí não, sem a medicação. 66. Eu falei:
"Nossa, tem uma cor coisa estranha". E
eu tomava de amicron. Às vezes eu olhava
da 88. Quando eu entrei no programa, eu
achava que eu ia eliminar muito, muito,
uns 10 kg. Ainda falei: "Nossa,
emagrecer 10 kg, tô feliz". E hoje eu
posso dizer que eu emagreci 21. Mas eu
tô tão feliz. Eu, doutor, eu vestia 50,
eu tô vestindo 42.
>> Olha isso, né? A Gele, ela enfermeira,
acesso a médicos, acesso à informação
e ela, profissional da saúde, não sabia
direito sobre resistência insulínica.
Então, você que é uma pessoa leiga, que
não é da área da saúde, você não é
obrigado a saber sobre isso, mas quando
você vai no médico, ele é obrigado a te
explicar o porquê, por que que você tem
que tratar, por que que você tá acima do
peso, sabe? Começa a se perguntar mais
sobre os porquês, porque isso vai trazer
tanta consciência para você.
Principalmente quando você se pergunta,
pera aí, por que
que eu vou me abandonar? O que que eu
vou ganhar com isso? Por que que eu vou
deixar sempre para depois? Que que eu
vou ganhar com isso?
E olha só, 10 kg em 45 dias ao todo 21
kg, plantonista noturna, resistência
insulínica, alteração de fígado,
alteração de tireoide.
E olha a barriga, lembra que eu
expliquei para você sobre a barriga,
sobre gordura visceral? que é relação de
cortisol, resistência insulínica. Então,
independente se você tá aí
com alteração do sono, você que
amamenta, você que tem trabalho noturno,
se a gente consegue regular isso, você
consegue perder peso. Olha a diferença
da circunferência abdominal da Gisele e
autoestima, né? você volta a se sentir
bonita, volta a ter energia, energia
para trabalhar. [roncando]
Só que isso você não consegue somente
cuidando da base hormonabólica, porque a
base hormonabólica é um dos pilares e
você precisa aprender tudo sobre o quê?
Ciclagem de dietas, que é o nosso
segundo pilar.
Então, vamos lá. Eu quero que vocês hoje
esqueçam tudo que vocês sabem sobre
dietas, porque o que você vai aprender
agora faz você emagrecer duas vezes mais
rápido, sem entrar no efeito platô.
sem estagnar,
sem entrar no efeito platô, sem
estagnar. Então vamos lá. Que que vocês
fazem de dieta para tentar emagrecer?
Você cortam carboidrato, come só salada
e carne. Quem nunca fez isso? Vou tirar
o arroz da minha vida. Dieta de três em
três horas. Você come uma, duas vezes no
dia. Você faz dieta da sopa, dieta do
ovo, dieta da lua, dieta da proteína,
shake, substituto de refeição, chás. Ah,
vou substituir a alimentação, tudo por
chá. E eu te pergunto, qual que é a
dieta perfeita? O que que você já tentou
de dieta para tentar perder peso? Alguém
sabe me responder qual a dieta perfeita,
hein?
Alguém sabe qual a dieta perfeita?
Não existe dieta perfeita.
Todas as dietas funcionam quando
aplicada na ordem certa, na ordem
correta.
Todas as dietas funcionam. Só qual que é
o problema? Você quer fazer uma única
dieta por 2, 3 meses?
Vai dar errado. Você quer seguir o mesmo
padrão alimentar por meses. Vai dar
errado. Seu corpo vai se adaptar a tudo
o que você faz. E aí eu quero te fazer
uma pergunta aqui.
Quando eu falo dieta,
que sensação que isso te dá? Dieta?
Vamos lá. Não, não tô falando. Esquece.
Faz de conta que você não tinha, não me
conhecia até aqui. Quando eu falo a
palavra dieta,
qual a sensação você tem?
[roncando]
Dá até uma tremedeira, né, quando você
ouve a palavra dieta.
Porque na sua cabeça a palavra dieta,
devido a todos os traumas de reganho de
peso que você teve, a palavra dieta, ela
não soa como esperança de algo que vai
acontecer positivo, não.
Ela quer dizer, sabe o quê? Nossa, de
novo. Não dá uma sensação do de novo?
Que que vocês sentem quando vocês ouvem
a palavra dieta?
Lá tem gente derrota, terrorismo,
restrição, fome, pânico,
privação,
passar fome, tristeza,
dieta é igual a de novo. Essa sensação
do de novo mais uma vez,
porque você já errou, já engordou muitas
vezes, né? E principalmente se fala
segunda-feira, aí que vem dieta
segunda-feira na mesma frase. Gente,
acabou. Eu quero te perguntar uma coisa
aqui.
Você já tentou montar? Por exemplo, você
vai lá e compra um guarda-roupa
e o guarda-roupa chega na caixa para
você? Você já tentou montar um
guarda-roupa? Você pega e não vem
manual, não tem ninguém para te ajudar.
vai montar um guarda-roupa, vai ficar
tudo torto, vai ficar tudo empenado.
Você vai lá, monta, aperta tudo e a hora
que você vê fica torto, a porta não
fecha direito, fica empenada, aí você
desmonta o guarda-roupa. Vamos tentar de
novo. Vamos olhar na internet como é que
monta esse guarda-roupa e fica ruim de
novo. Você não, você não desiste. Você
tenta. Pera aí, deixa eu dar mais uma
apertadinha aqui nesse parafuso aqui
para ver se fica melhor essa porta.
Só que chega um momento, você desiste,
fala assim: "Ah, não aguento". Tá, se
deixa esse guarda-roupa do jeito que tá
mesmo, porque não vou conseguir chamar
alguém que vai me ajudar mais. Já até
estraguei, já até empenou o, já até
roçou os parafusos todos desse
guarda-roupa. É exatamente o que
acontece em cada dieta que você fez até
aqui, porque você monta tudo no esforço,
na força bruta, você tenta fazer dieta
de qualquer jeito, sem o manual correto,
sem o acompanhamento correto, sem a
estratégia correta.
E você até perde uns quilinhos no
primeiro momento, mas depois, gente,
acabou, volta tudo de novo, volta
compulsão, volta fome. Você se priva do
que você gosta, você deixa de ter prazer
na vida, você passa a se privar de
convívio social. E aí toda vez que você
recomeça, por que que você recomeça?
Porque você falhou. O seu recomeço, ele
não tem motivo
feliz por trás, ele tem o motivo de um
fracasso que existiu. E é por isso que
eu preciso dizer uma coisa que eu vejo
em muitas de vocês aqui que vocês
falaram pra gente ao longo da última
semana.
Eh,
não existe
mulher sem jeito. Ah, eu não tenho jeito
para fazer dieta.
Existe uma pessoa que tentou 30 vezes a
coisa errada.
Então eu quero que agora vocês assumem
um compromisso de parar de brigar com o
corpo de vocês, de parar de se culpar,
de parar de pelo amor de Deus, eu não
dar conta, eu sou fracassado, eu não
tenho força de vontade. Tira esse papo
de falta de força de vontade. Vocês têm
força de vontade, senão vocês não
estariam aqui.
Então eu quero que agora vocês retirem
essa palavra recomeçar. Vou recomeçar do
zero. Não, eu quero que você mude. Eu
vou começar do jeito certo. Entendido?
Todo mundo agora. Eu vou começar do
jeito certo porque senão você fica aí
com chicote se castigando o tempo
inteiro quando você começa uma dieta na
segunda-feira.
Então, tira a palavra de novo. Vou fazer
mais uma dieta de novo. Vou recomeçar de
novo, vou tentar emagrecer de novo? Não
fala assim: "Agora eu vou fazer do jeito
certo, vou fazer por mim, porque eu me
amo, quero me cuidar, quero viver mais,
quero ver melhor, quero me sentir
bonita, quero entrar na roupa que eu
quiser, quero ter autoestima, quero ser
a pessoa que eu mereço ser." Porque não
é recomeço,
porque o recomeço ele vem através de
culpa.
Eu falo assim: "Eu vou começar do jeito
certo". Ponto.
E não começa sozinha, porque sozinha
você sabe que vai dar errado.
Sozinha você sabe que vai dar errado. E
é por isso que eu preciso te ensinar
tudo sobre ciclagem e dietas pra gente
tirar esse medo. Porque imagina que
legal toda semana você trocar de dieta.
P que legal isso, sabe? Dá vontade, você
fica animada, sempre tem a sensação do
novo. Vou começar agora de novo, vou,
opa, tiro de novo. Vou começar do jeito
certo. Vou começar essa nova dieta. Vou
começar essa nova dieta toda semana.
Imagina que legal isso.
Porque não é de novo, é diferente.
O de novo é você querer ter um resultado
diferente fazendo o que você fazia
antes, fazendo a mesma coisa.
Então vamos entender qual que é o ciclo
típico das dietas aqui. Ciclo típico das
dietas, meninas, [roncando]
você vai lá, faz uma dieta, fase de
empolgação, peso cai, você tá
animadíssima, de repente, freio
metabólico, seu corpo, ele vai fazer o
possível para travar seu emagrecimento,
porque o corpo entende o emagrecimento
como caminho pra morte e ele vai
bloquear seu emagrecimento, começa a
diminuir velocidade de emagrecimento. Aí
entra no quê? No efeito platô. Entrou no
efeito platô, você ainda acredita, fala:
"Não, deve ser só uma fase, vai voltar a
perder peso, só que não volta a perder
peso". E você continua estagnada. E aí
vem um problema que é a compensação de
dopamina. Dopamina é o neurotransmissor
do prazer.
Neurotransmissor do prazer.
Você viu que não tá tendo resultado,
aquela motivação vai embora e aí
dopamina cai. Dopamina cai, você sente
triste e fala: "Ah, não serve para mim".
E você começa o quê? A buscar fontes de
dopamina. Quais são as fontes de
dopamina? Comida, doce, o chocolate,
bebida, vícios. E você começa a
compensar a falta de dopamina porque
perdeu a motivação comendo. E aí vem as
últimas duas fases. Fase de abandono,
começa a ter reganho de peso. Você teve
o reganho de peso, vem o quê? A falta de
culpa. Quer dizer, a vem a fase da
culpa. E quando você sente culpa, você
não tem controle mais. E aí você perde o
controle e fala: "Vou me aceitar desse
jeito". Não é assim que acontece?
Não é assim que acontece com vocês?
Porque vocês acham que que para
emagrecer precisa ser muito
disciplinada?
E você acha que a disciplina é ser
perfeita? Não,
a disciplina é você fazer mesmo tendo
errado no dia anterior.
E a dieta tradicional faz o que com o
seu metabolismo? Então, te faz perder
peso no primeiro momento, estagna e você
não consegue emagrecer mais.
Já com as ciclagens dietas é diferente.
Então, quais são as dietas, gente? Essas
aqui são as principais. Low carb, dieta
tradicional. essa dieta, né,
equilibradinha ali de de nutrio que você
vai, dieta de três em 3 horas, dietas
com mais carboidratos, menos gorduras,
dietas com mais gorduras, menos
carboidratos, um detox, trocas
inteligentes. O que que é trocas
inteligentes? Eu acho que vocês nunca
ouviram falar. Trocas inteligentes é
você para fazer uma adaptação, você
passa
a manter o mesmo padrão alimentar só
trocando o tipo de alimento, sem
diminuir, só para adaptar, porque tem
gente que precisa passar por uma
adaptação. Jejum, reintegração
alimentar. Você sabe o que que é
reintegração alimentar? Qual a forma
mais eficiente de você sair do efeito
platô? Sabe qual a forma mais eficiente
de você sair do efeito platô? Comendo
mais.
Come mais por um tempo saudável, seu
corpo, metabolismo sobe. Então tem gente
que precisa comer mais no primeiro
momento. Todas essas dietas funcionam.
Todas as dietas funcionam no momento
certo, na sequência certa. Vai ter
momento que eu preciso colocar mais
gordura e menos carboidrato. Vai ter
momento que eu coloco mais carboidrato,
menos gordura. Eu quero que vocês
entendam o poder de cada uma dessas
dietas no seu metabolismo. Vamos lá,
então. Só para você entender. Então,
dieta restritiva,
peso cai, estagna, ganha. Trocas de
dietas, que é ciclagem de dietas. Qual o
que que tem? O que que é o termo
ciclagem dietas? Ciclag de dieta. Começa
uma dieta, troco antes do corpo se
adaptar. Então eu troco de dieta antes
do corpo se adaptar aquela dieta.
E aí o que acontece? Peso cai de forma
contínua, metabolismo acelerando.
E por que que ciclagem dietas funcionam
para todo mundo? Porque o nosso corpo
ele não foi projetado para um único
padrão alimentar.
Se você pegar na pré-história, não
precisa nem ser pré-história, tá?
Pré-história. Tinha dia que tinha
comida, tinha dia que não tinha. Então,
na nossa evolução, nós vivemos em
períodos de abundância e escassez. E eu
não preciso nem ir muito, muito
antigamente, não. Vamos falar na época
da minha mãe. Minha mãe tem 12 11
irmãos, são 12 filhos no total.
Minha avó era dona de casa
e às vezes lavava roupa para para
vizinho. Meu avô, ele trabalhava na
Ferroviária. Sou de Lavras, Minas
Gerais. Moro em São Paulo, mas eu sou lá
do sul de Minas.
Meu avô, ele trabalhava na ferroviária,
ele colocava dormente em linha férrea,
sabe? aquela aquelas madeiras lá na
finha ferra. Então assim, família muito
pobre mesmo, muito humilde [roncando] e
não tinha carne. Minha mãe falava assim:
"Ah, carne era no na no domingo porque
tinha um galinheiro em casa, era só no
domingo que tinha carne". [roncando]
E aí tinha época, né, que não tinha.
Então assim, era período de escassez e
abundância. Isso eu tô falando, gente,
da minha mãe, coisa recente. Imagina o
período de 100 anos atrás. 200 anos
atrás,
o nosso corpo acostumou nossa biologia
com período de abundância cassilação no
padrão alimentar.
Então, você acha que uma única dieta vai
funcionar para sempre? Não, porque seu
corpo ele criou a capacidade de
adaptação pela sobrevivência
devido a esses períodos de escassez na
na infância, na no passado,
entende? Por isso que ciclar dietas
funcionam tão bem. Quais os erros que
vocês cometem ao ciclar dieta, fazer
ciclar dietas? Se você fizer na
sequência errada dietas, você engorda e
não emagrece. Se você fizer o tempo
errado de cada ciclagem, também não
adianta, porque tem ciclagem que eu
consigo prolongar um pouquinho mais, tem
ciclagem que tem que ser um pouquinho
mais curta para causar choque no
metabolismo. E se você errar a
quantidade de alimentos, você também não
perde peso. Então a, gente, eu já
quebrei cabeça com isso, viu? Essa
estratégia de ciclagem dietas eu
desenvolvi há 8 anos atrás, só que lá
atrás eu quebrava a cabeça até eu chegar
numa sequência perfeita que acelera o
processo de emagrecimento.
Grava isso daqui. Isso aqui é muito
importante para você entender o
mecanismo por trás da ciclagem de
dietas.
Quando você tem uma tireoide alterada,
você que tem aí o TSH de 2.3 para cima
ou você que toma remédio tireoide e não
repõe o T3, se você tem alteração de
tireoide, seu metabolismo pode estar uns
50% abaixo. Então não tem dieta que te
faz perder peso. Se você tem alteração
de cortisol, seu metabolismo pode estar
uns 25% abaixo. Se você tem um sono
ruim, seu metabolismo pode estar uns 25%
abaixo. Intestino preso uns 15% abaixo.
E quem tem resistência insulínica
bloqueia queima de gordura.
E se você tem problema em tudo isso, seu
metabolismo vai est uns 50% abaixo.
E o que que ciclagem de dietas faz nisso
aqui?
A conexão da ciclagem de dietas com base
hormonal metabólica. Ciclagem de dietas
não é só contagem de calorias,
é isso aqui.
Presta atenção. Quando você faz um
detox, que que eu tô querendo com detox?
melhorar intestino, fígado e
consequentemente conversão dos hormônios
da tireoide, porque eu melhorei o
fígado. Quando você faz uma reativação
do metabolismo que você come mais, é
para aumentar o metabolismo, para
aumentar o gasto energético, porque
depois que você come mais e eu reduzo a
dieta, você destravou o metabolismo.
Quando eu faço uma dieta com mais
carboidrato, eu tô pensando em sono e
tireoide. Uma dieta com mais gordura, tô
pensando em saciedade, grelina, leptina.
Claro, vai ajudar em perfil de de
insulina e glicose. E uma dieta low
cararb, tô pensando em insulina,
glicose, colesterol.
Por isso que eu preciso ciclar as
estratégias, porque uma ciclagem de
dietas por si só começa a tratar vários
componentes da base hormonal metabólica.
Esse é o ponto percebido aqui que eu
quero que vocês entendam. Dieta não é só
contar calorias. Existe um componente
hormonal por trás. Por isso que você vai
num nutrire. pode ser um nutre legal da
sociedade. Ele fez um cálculo em cima de
calorias e você não consegue manter o
emagrecimento, você vive no efeito
sanfona, porque essa dieta não foi
pensada pelo perfil hormonal metabólico
que você tem.
E daí nós temos algumas dúvidas que
vocês mandaram pra gente relacionado
a emagrecimento, velocidade de
emagrecimento. Então, olha só, dúvidas
que vocês mandaram pra gente nos últimos
dias. Então, olha só, Dr. Renan, por que
que dessa vez é diferente? Já fiz 1000
dietas e o peso voltou.
Se você tem esse tipo de dúvida, agora a
gente sana essa dúvida por conta da
compreensão de ciclagem dietas. Então
não é que você falhou, é estratégia.
Você faz um único padrão alimentar e seu
corpo se adapta. E dentro de uma
ciclagem de dietas isso não acontece.
Então por mais que você já tentou muitas
coisas, não existe um profissional que
você vai onde você vai sair com 14
dietas.
As minhas alunas, elas têm as 14 dietas,
mais do que isso. Mas nenhum
profissional vai montar 14 dietas para
você em uma hora de consulta. Ah, mas eu
tenho problema de tireoide. Será que eu
tenho jeito?
Quando você tem problema de tireide, seu
metabolismo, acabei de falar, fica um
50% abaixo. Se você faz uma dieta com
muita restrição de carboidrato por muito
tempo, você não vai otimizar tireide.
Então, preciso entrar em algum momento
com carboidrato e, claro, você tem que
fazer reposição do T3. Outra coisa, eu
tô na menopausa, meu metabolismo já era,
Dr. Renan, não tem mais o que fazer.
Menopausa é desculpa.
Menopausa não impede ninguém de
emagrecer. O problema da menopausa é que
seus hormônios começam a terar sono.
Alterou sono. Você já hoje entendeu a
relação do sono com os hormônios da
tireoide, a relação do sono com
metabolismo, com cortisol.
Só que você chega no no ginecologista e
não trata o seu sono, ele quer te passar
só o hormônio. Eu sou a favor de
reposição hormonal quando bem feita e
quando tem indicação. Sou a favor.
[roncando]
Não é uma questão de ser a favor, uma
questão de ciência, tá? Tem benefício,
tem gente que não pode usar e tem gente
que não quer,
mas não é reposição hormonal que vai te
emagrecer. Outra dúvida aqui que vocês
mandaram pra gente, mas eu tenho
compulsão alimentar e ansiedade. Eu não
consigo seguir nada até o fim. Você acha
que é falta de força de vontade? você aa
acha que é falta de disciplina, tira
essa palavra da sua cabeça. A forma como
você acredita que você é, você começa a
se comportar como tal. Se você se acha
uma pessoa indisciplinada,
que não dá conta, preguiçosa, você
começa a se comportar dessa forma.
Então, compulsão e ansiedade tem relação
com o nosso eixo sono intestino
por causa da baixa de serotonina. Quando
melhor sono intestino não é mais uma
falta de força de vontade, você começa a
conseguir, fica muito mais fluido.
Outra dúvida que vocês mandaram pra
gente, não consigo viver de jejum o
tempo todo, mas jejum das estratégias,
que é a estratégia que vocês estão
seguindo essa semana. O jejum é o
primeiro degrau que vocês têm aqui
nesses s dias.
Ninguém precisa passar fome para
emagrecer. Vai ter dieta que você tem
que comer mais e às vezes você nem dá
conta do tanto que você tem que comer.
Ah, mas eu acho que eu não vou conseguir
porque eu já desisti tantas vezes. Quem
disse que você desistiu?
Você fez alguma coisa que não deu certo
e você abandonou por ver que não tava
dando certo. Mas por que que não tava
dando certo? O, a pergunta não é
por que que eu desisti. A pergunta é por
que que eu não Por que que não deu certo
para mim? E a resposta é porque você tem
alteração de base hormonal metabólica.
Pode ser o eixo da tríade que eu ensinei
ontem, tireoide, cortisol, insulina,
pode ser o eixo intestino do sono. Por
isso, sua dieta não funciona pra maioria
de vocês. E você desistia porque não
tinha resultado, mas não tinha resultado
porque te trataram da forma errada.
Outra dúvida. Ah, mas eu tenho medo de
me frustrar de novo de com todas as
outras vezes. [roncando]
Mas nas outras vezes que você fez, você
seguia uma única dieta ou você fazia
dieta nova toda semana? O seu medo ele
ele tem sentido. Eu sei que muitas de
vocês entraram aqui com medo do nosso
desafio. Será que Dr. Renão vai estar
aqui? Será que não vai estar? Será que
ele vai entregar? Eu espero que eu tenha
superado as expectativas de vocês,
porque a gente sempre entrega muito mais
do que a gente promete.
Só que você hoje não tá mais no mesmo
lugar, porque hoje você tem um
conhecimento sobre você que você nunca
teve, que nenhuma consulta médica te
deu.
Ai, mas eu não tenho disciplina, sempre
começo animada e desisto no meio do
caminho.
Ninguém nasce disciplinada. A disciplina
ela é construída com a repetição que a
gente pega na mão de vocês para essa
repetição. Então não é que falta
disciplina, falta uma direção.
Ah, mas será que eu consigo sozinha?
Vamos lá. Você já saiu daqui, você já
tem um mapa, já sabe sobre intestino,
sono, ciclagem, hormônios, metabolismo.
Você já tem o seu radar de problema,
sabe o seu perfil hormonal? Se você
sentinela, refém, sobrecarregada ou
acorrentada
ou prisioneira, desculpa, que tá
acorrentada, você já sabe o seu perfil,
você já tem estratégias para começar a
tratar,
você tem conhecimento sobre você, mas eu
sei que às vezes sozinha é difícil.
Então, quero dizer mais uma vez, a culpa
não é sua, mas agora você tem um
conhecimento. Eu te pergunto, o que que
você vai fazer com esse conhecimento?
Vai guardar na gaveta? Vai se abandonar
mais uma vez ou você vai se cuidar?
Porque foi exatamente isso que a Carol
fez. A Carol, ela tava num dilema, como
muitas de vocês. A Carol, você acredita?
Mesmo muito acima do peso, ela tinha
pontuação baixa, pontuação baixa no
mapa. E ela tinha um problema hormonal.
Sabe qual resistência à insulina? Ela
tinha um problema hormonal.
Olha aqui, ó. Nunca pensei que teria
tantas informações. É isso. É isso que
eu quero surpreender vocês mesmo. A
Carol tinha um problema hormonal,
resistência a insulina.
A gente precisava tratar isso. E ela
perdeu 16 kg em 45 dias e ao todo 42 kg
como a Luna PEF 360.
Então não é só ficar pulando de dieta em
dieta, não adianta você pegar dietas
antigas e seguindo. Precisa de uma
lógica por trás da sua individualidade
hormonal.
Amanhã na nossa quinta aula, a gente vai
falar sobre isso aqui, ó. A mochila das
amarras invisíveis. Amanhã é a aula mais
especial de todas. Eu quero todo mundo
aqui comigo, porque você não precisa
carregar tudo isso aqui sozinho. A gente
vai começar a libertar você dessas
amarras invisíveis. Quais são as amarras
invisíveis? os medos, os traumas, as
frustrações, o autoabandono,
autossabotagem, a as desculpas da vida,
da falta de tempo, tristeza, falta de
alegria. Você que vive desanimada, sente
preguiçosa, se sente incapaz, falta
disciplina, motivação, depressão,
ansiedade.
Você que não se sente merecedora, você
que não se sente amada, amanhã a aula
cinca é para você. Porque enquanto essa
mochila das amarras invisíveis estiver
carregada,
emagrecer é impossível.
Mas a gente vai começar a descarregar
essa sua mochila das amarras invisíveis
amanhã.
Você sofre com algum desses problemas
aqui dessas amarras invisíveis?
Amanhã a gente vai começar a tirar essas
amarras invisíveis de vocês
na aula 5 amanhã, que é linda a aula,
maravilhosa.
E temos agora a nossa quarta chave
secreta, meninas. O que que é a nossa
quarta chave secreta dessa aula?
Dois. e-books completo, um e-book
completo, sobretudo sobre ciclagem e
dietas e um e-book completo sobre o
tratamento do eixo sono intestino.
Presentaços aqui para vocês. E aqui, ó,
deixa eu mostrar uma outra coisa. Eu sei
que é muita coisa, ó. E temos agora o
bônus que a gente vai liberar, né? Nosso
quarto bônus. Eu sei que é muita coisa
incrível nessa semana. Eu quero dar o
parabéns para vocês. Sabe por quê?
Porque vocês acreditaram no nosso
trabalho, que é o nosso propósito de
levar saúde, levar conhecimento,
informação de alto valor para que você
tenha capacidade de transformar sua
vida. Eu quero dar os parabéns para
vocês, porque vocês estão aqui comigo
todo dia ao vivo, né, assistindo as
aulas, se comprometendo, acordando cedo,
indo dormir mais cedo, se programando
para est aqui, porque eu pedi lá no
começo da semana para você se priorizar.
Então, a partir de agora, eu quero que
você nunca mais aceite menos do que você
merece. Nunca mais. Não aceite ninguém
te tratar como um número, olhar os seus
exames e falar: "Ah, tá tudo bem com
você, toma aqui só um remédio para
emagrecer e segue sua vida e toma aqui
uma dieta de gaveta". Nunca mais aceite
menos do que você merece, porque eu sei
que nessa semana vocês estão vivendo
aqui o quê? Um universo paralelo. É o
verdadeiro universo paralelo da saúde,
de conhecimento, de libertação. Porque
você agora conhece sobre você? Lá na
nossa primeira aula, eu falei, vocês
agora têm um nível de conhecimento sobre
vocês. O nosso desafio é sobre você.
Você hoje sabe muito mais sobre você do
que você sabia antes de chegar aqui. E
eu espero fortemente que você continue
nesse universo paralelo. E existe uma
forma de você continuar nesse universo
paralelo que através do PEF 360. O PEF
360 é o meu programa de emagrecimento e
saúde mais completo. Não é só sobre
emagrecimento. Tem mulheres que entram
para ter qualidade de vida e nem
emagrecer.
No PEF 360, eu sou seu médico ali
dentro, eu peço, analiso seus exames,
você tem o seu tratamento
individualizado para você perder todos
quilos que você precisar.
Acesso a todo o meu time de nutri junto
com você, desenhando todo o tratamento,
desde alimentação até sua devolutiva,
com tudo que você precisa de forma
individualizada. A gente pega na mão, no
pé todo dia junto com vocês. Mas agora a
nossa aula ficou um pouco longa, eu não
consigo entrar nos detalhes do PEF 360,
mas eu prometo que amanhã na nossa aula
sim eu trago todos os detalhes para
vocês. Eu também vou dar prioridade para
vocês que estão participando do nosso
desafio. Como assim prioridade? Porque
as vagas do PEF elas são verdadeiramente
limitadas, porque esse nível de
acompanhamento individualizado eu não
consigo fazer por um número grande de
pessoas.
Então vocês estão participando do
desafio, eu vou dar prioridade para
vocês, paraa nossa próxima turma do PEF.
Mas
eu preciso falar por que eu tô dando
prioridade. Porque eu tenho uma lista de
espera de mulheres que não conseguiram
entrar. E ali no Instagram tem mais de 9
milhões de seguidores no Instagram, mais
de 1.8 milhões milhão no YouTube, mas eu
dou prioridade para vocês aqui, mas
amanhã eu trago mais informações sobre o
PEF 360 para vocês, meninos. E agora nós
temos a nossa quarta,
o quarto bônus da nossa quarta aula,
meninas. E o que que é o quarto bônus?
Protocolo antiinchaço 48 horas. E o que
que é esse protocolo antiinchaço 48
horas? Então aqui, olha só, esse nosso
protocolo antiinchaço, 48 horas é um
material que vocês recebem, onde vocês
vão ter listinchar
de forma rápida, com indicação de chás
que ajudam a desinchar e uma análise
para você entender o porque que você é
inchada, porque que você tem retenção de
líquido. Então você vai ter todo o
material e com essa análise, você
entendendo quais hormônios te deixam
inchado, o que que por que você fica
inchada. Então não é só uma dica. Hoje
você também vai entender o por que você
vive enchada. Quem vive inchada é porque
você tem alguma alteração de quê?
Metabólica. Mas qual alteração
metabólica? Porque não adianta só tomar
chá para desinchar se a causa não for
tratada.
Entendidos? E como que vocês pegam nossa
quarta, o nosso quarto bônus? Eu vou
liberar daqui a pouco para vocês a nossa
lista de presença. Você tem que assinar
a lista de presença e depois que você
assina a lista de presença, no final vai
ter o link para você baixar o protocolo
antiinchaço 48 horas.
Mas antes de liberar o o link aqui para
vocês, nós estamos aqui construindo na
semana a pirâmide de reconexão.
O que que é essa pirâmide de reconexão?
Eu ensinei vocês a olharem para vocês
mesmos com mais atenção. Lembra que eu
falei: "Eu me olho,
eu me valorizo, eu tenho
[limpando a garganta] valor". Essas
hashtags que eu peço para vocês
colocarem nos posts não é só, gente,
para encher comentário. Eu não preciso
disso não. Eu não preciso disso. Se
vocês forem olhar lá com todo post que
eu passo, passa de 10.000 comentários,
20.000 comentários. Tem post de 100.000
comentários. Eu não preciso disso. Isso
não muda nada na minha vida, mas faz
parte do trabalho de construção dessa
reconexão com vocês mesmas. Então, hoje,
eh,
a ponta dessa pirâmide de reconexão, que
é um um uma das tarefas mais importantes
do nosso post do desafio. Por quê? Eu
quero que você volte a se amar.
Independente do peso que você tem hoje,
você tem que começar a fazer essa
reconexão com você para que você se
sinta merecedora do resultado de saúde
que você vai ter. Porque se você não se
acha merecedora,
não adianta. Você pode ter o melhor
acompanhamento, fazer melhor dieta, ter,
perder 30 kg, que você vai ganhar tudo
de novo. Porque quando você perde peso,
você recupera sua saúde, você sente bem,
só que você sente merecedora,
você não quer perder isso porque é um
presente que você se deu. Então nós
temos hoje, ó, eu vou fazer esse post,
vai ser o post da nossa aula, do
desafio, da hashtag da nossa aula,
porque eu quero que você volte a se
amar. Então, vou postar, fazer esse post
aqui, ó, no meu perfil do Instagram e eu
quero que vocês vão lá e coloquem #eamo.
Estão desafiadas, mas é no post do
Instagram, #eu meamo. E você vai falar
o por que você merece fazer isso por
você. Ou você pode falar o que que você
achou dessa aula. Enfim, fala o que você
quiser, mas o mais importante é você lá
#umamo.
Do porquê que você se se ama? Porque
agora eu me enxergo, porque agora eu
consigo me olhar, porque agora eu
descobri isso, porque agora já aconteceu
isso na minha vida em uma semana. Coloca
lá #umamo. Então, estão desafiadas
saindo dessa aula, vocês vão no nosso
post do
Instagram.
Por quê? Porque esses posts contam
pontinhos pra gente escolher campeã do
concurso que vai rolar no final da
semana. E o que que é o concurso?
Primeiro tem um sorteio. Para você
participar do sorteio, vai, está rolando
essa, vai rolar no final, na última aula
da aula de domingo, um sorteio ao vivo
desse kit de suplementos. E para você
participar do sorteio, você tem que
preencher todas as listas de presença.
Todas as listas de presença. Aí você tá
apto a participar do sorteio. Pílula do
pãozinho, que é uma fórmula desenvolvida
por mim que atrapalha a absorção de
refeição livre. Vai comer uma pizza com
sua família, toma isso aqui antes. O
gelzinho dos sonhos que as alunas amam.
Isso aqui já ajuda na libido feminina. e
o fitoterápico que ajuda em energia e
disposição. Então esse kit de
suplementos eu não vendo suplementos, é
uma, são fórmulas envolvidas por mim que
eu mando para sua casa, pra casa da
campeã de sorteio. Vou fazer sorteio ao
vivo no domingo. E temos o concurso que
tá rolando. O que que é o concurso? Eu
vou liberar uma tarefa no final da
semana e para você participar do do
concurso, você tem que preencher todas
as listas de presença. Essas hashtags
dos nossos posts contam pontos. As
hashtags dos nossos posts contam pontos.
para você ganhar pontinhos. Não é
obrigatório, mas contam pontos.
E a campeã do concurso ganha análise
individualizada do mapa de emagrecimento
dela.
Ela ganha o kit de suplementos
e ela ganha a vaga garantida na próxima
turma do PEF 360, que é o meu programa
de emagrecimento feminino mais completo
com o meu acompanhamento, eu sendo o
médico dela, da campeã, com acesso a
todo o meu time para ela cuidar da
saúde,
emagrecer todos aquilos que precisar e
que quiser.
Então, vale a pena vocês serem engajadas
participativas, viu, meninas?
Amanhã então nós trabalharemos a
mochila, a sua mochila
de todo esse peso emocional que você
tem.
A gente vai começar a trabalhar na nossa
quinta aula, sociedade, suas emoções,
começar a tirar essas amarras
invisíveis,
combinados? É uma aula muito especial. A
nossa aula 5 de amanhã é linda.
E eu vou construir amanhã com vocês ao
vivo o plano perfeito do seu
emagrecimento. Então é uma aula surreal.
O link da
lista de presença está no chat, meninas.
Um beijo. Vejo vocês amanhã na nossa
quinta aula do desafio do jejum. Mais
uma vez muito obrigado pela presença de
todas e quero todo mundo aqui comigo ao
vivo amanhã. Tá bom, meninas? Um beijo,
vejo vocês.
Eu tive trombose na perna esquerda
[música] por causa disso tive que
retirar útero, colocas.
E depois logo já fiz a cirurgia [música]
de varizes. Foi tratamento com 40 g de
rivar, 900 mg de Dios diosmin. E com
[música] isso, desde abril até aqui, até
semana passada, eu tinha engordado 8 kg.
De 98, fui para 106. Eu tava com falta
de ar, a minha perna muito [música]
inchada também. Estou na menopausa há há
3 anos e tenho 60 anos, [música] né? E
foi um efeito sanfona, isso foi muito
traumático para mim. E agora parece que
[música] ficou mais difícil perder por
conta da minha idade, né? Já fiz
tratamento com suplementos, com
vitaminas, com chás, só que só ven
engordando. Retirei o glúten, o leite,
sofro muito com isso, sinto muitas dores
na barriga, tenho problema de alopécia e
como você vê aqui, ó, meu cabelo
continua caindo, toma minoxidil, tem uma
super falha aqui no meu início aqui, ó,
do do cabelo. Desde os 32 anos eu faço
várias dietas aí tentando emagrecer e
manter o peso. Eu chego até emagrecer,
sabe? Mas eh com o tempo [música] eu vou
entrando no efeito platô e acabo
engordando novamente. Então foram várias
várias [música] tentativas de emagrecer
durante todos esses anos, dos 32 ao 70
que eu estou hoje. E isso me prejudicou
muito a minha massa muscular. em algumas
[música] delas e chegou a afetar até um
pouco dos meus ossos. Aos 45 anos foi
detectado em mim o hipotiroidismo
[música]
e desde então eu tomo o Cintroide. Mas
eu tenho todos aqueles sintomas que o
Dr. Renan fala no nosso curso. Eu tenho
[música]
unhas fracas, meu cabelo cresce muito
devagarzinho, tá fraquinho também, minha
pele [música] é seca, eu tenho dores
pelo corpo. São vários, vários sintomas
que eu tenho. Tive dois filhos e casei
com 53 kg e hoje tô aqui com 69 kg eu
estava. e nunca conseguiu emagrecer o
suficiente para ter os exames eficazes.
Hoje eu tô com colesterol 332.
Olá, meu nome é Ideia, tenho 76 anos e
confesso que entrei nesse [música]
desafio desacreditando, porque já
participei de outros, que emagreci tanto
quanto, mas nenhum que me [música] desse
as instruções, os ensinamentos que eu
recebi com o Dr. Renan há muito tempo.
Venho travando lutas e lutas com
problemas de saúde. Eu tenho esteatose
hepática grau dois. Eu sou préulínica.
[música]
Eu tenho problemas
no pulmão, que eu tenho nódulos no
pulmão.
Há pouco tempo tive suspeita de câncer
no sangue. Aquela ficha
que nos foi dada de avaliação, eu
gabaritei 83 pontos. 83 pontos naquela
avaliação, porque tem problema de
insônia, sou tem problema de estresse,
tive queda no cabelo. Olha só aqui a
entrada. Eu tinha três vezes mais o
cabelo que eu tenho. Eu eliminei 3,800.
E assim eu senti que a minha perna
desinchou, minha falta de ar passou e eu
quero continuar. Eu entrei no cinco em
sete, perdi 3,
e para mim foi uma vitória.
>> Tava com 85 kg, 700, hoje estou com
81,900. Estampar de 3 kg
800 g.
>> Diminuir 5 cm de cintura e 3,5 [música]
kg durante o desafio cinco em 7.
>> E eu tenho certeza que agora vai. Agora
desbloqueou.
Aí a chavinha e eliminei 3,900 em 5
dias.
>> E eu tô feliz que eu consegui 4 kg
assim, sabe? Ainda falta até domingo, eu
tô fazendo tudo certinho e eu tô muito
esperançosa. Muito esperançosa. É
gratidão minha palavra para você,
doutor. Muito obrigada. Dessa vez eu
encontrei o caminho certo. Eu tô muito
feliz por isso. Quando eu comecei essa
semana, eu tava com 102 kg e hoje, para
minha surpresa, [música]
quando eu subi na balança, eu tava com
98 kg. Então assim, eu vi que realmente
eu tive um um sucesso que eu nunca antes
alcancei, sabe, nessa minha luta de
assim constante, essa luta secular,
[música]
né, contra a balança.
>> Muito obrigada, Dr. Renan. Muito
obrigada, equipe. Muito obrigada por
devolverem o meu sonho. Não sonho de de
beleza, mas meu sonho de ter saúde para
brincar com meu netinho. É uma graça.